[Music]
a female host of disasters rodas
to affirm their son has a
sign in this constituent chain
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
there is
I don't know
there
and
[Music]
hello to you I hope  you are
well our desire for an
important summit after these
European elections last weekend
which I believe sent us several
clear messages the first is that where
many thought that Europe was
tired of less and less democratic
our  peoples simply said that they
had wanted europe to
discuss europe
we had at european level a
participation rate which had not been
obtained for 25 years has been in france
since 1984 and therefore there is a
participation  which obliges all of
us then we are faced with a
real recomposition a new stage
in the European adventure for the
first time since the
European parliament has existed there is no majority
with two parties  and therefore there is the
need to build something else a
new project which is in the image of
what the European people have chosen and in
this respect the new central force
of progress that we are in the process of
building will obviously have a  role an
important responsibility in this
context I hope that today
we can also concentrate on
the substance, that is to say the heart of the project
that we want to lead in Europe over
the next five years the first
project is  to respond to the
climate emergency is a very strong message from
these elections in france but everywhere in
europe
we must build with those who carry
this vision and for our peoples
a very clear response at
european level on the climate issue
the second  thing is that we have to
rebuild the model of growth and
progress for our peoples
that means investing in
innovation artificial intelligence
new technologies continue to
work on the c  creation of jobs
in our economic area but also
to the standards of social minimums
because there is no economy which
will succeed if the people do
not do better
and if in particular in the countries where there
are today  he absence of a minimum
wage or social rights have
deteriorated and well if there is not a
return to a form of European convergence
third thing we need a
europe that protects more and I
hope that during the  five years to
come in terms of migration in
terms of protection of our borders
in terms of defense we can be
deported carry out ambitious projects
I have been able to
express mine but re-found in depth
schengen rebuild a common area of
tion and solidarity within our borde
s  having a real perspective of
common defense are essential elements
and then we must also move forward on
a deepening of the euro zone
france has been carrying for a long time  this project
we obtained agreements a
few months ago we must during these five
years
go much further in this respect
it is therefore a European ambition that
we must carry to build for the next five
years and we will have to choose
the  people on the basis of this
ambition we need women of
men who embodies this renewal who have
the experience and the credibility which
allows them to carry out its missions and which
reflects its ambitions and
wives fully this is what must
be focused on  my eyes our
discussion today and what are the criteria
for that
which embodies road although it
can first be found in this project that
the different
political philosophical sensitivities find their way
and and strong of the candidates that they  are
eligible that even embodies its ambitions
and who had the experience to
do so since these are
eminent responsibilities at
European level which supposes having
so many experiences  ient in his country is
already in europe which allows him to have the
credibility and the know-how
[Music]
he belongs to me I don't want today
that we talk about names or that we rush
on names I think  that we must
take into account what came out of the
ballot box is what the European people
express and we must also have
decision-makers who have the credibility required
to be able to act she is part of it, like
Mr. Barnier, like Ultimate Airlines
and several other people who have
precisely his skills to but i do
n't want today me in any case to have a
debate on the names i want to have a
debate on the project the priorities and the
criteria that we score populists in
colors wendy parages won in grand
marine  the pen has beaten you to a point
what is happening in europe and what
is happening in europe what I have been saying since
the beginning of my political commitment
many have wanted to say
lately President of the
French Republic and  exaggerate and dramatize the
situation they are trying to use this
situation I don't forget that
you and I come from a country that
five years ago had 1,000 national fronts in the
lead, moreover with a slightly
higher figure  than the one he has today than
two years ago at 1000 national front in the
second round
so it is not a discovery of
this election by all the extremes
show and it rises on what the fears
the lies the  help from
foreign powers who want to destroy the
European project and our inability to
provide an effective response to what
our fellow citizens are asking for, that is to say long
live in a continent at peace but
live better to have their share of progress
and also respond with hopes to the
contemporary fears are coming to
power
but they are coming
so that's why I put all my
energy myself in the
French countryside so that we hold on to this rank
because all in all false bricks
site we will have  s the forces of progress
will have the same number of
european parliamentarians as the national front that
was not given a few months ago
and then so that everywhere in
europe all the forces of progress
of the future can act together we have
at least  achieved one thing there is a
majority possible without the extremes it
was not given
a few months ago and that is because
we mobilized that we
have made progress now let's be clear
the five years to come at
European level these are the  five years during
which we have to demonstrate that
we know how to bring Europe back to life, that
we know how to carry out a clear project and
that we know how to once again convince our
fellow citizens that this is a project that is
good for them, otherwise they will be even
further towards the extremes
and three-dimensional nationalism
spend less massively voted and
notably you're not all of you
much greener of their expectation
it's true but as you have  also
noted I had understood it well even before
this election
and I think that it is in the action that
the government will have to lead in
this act 2 that I announced at the
press conference of April 25
one of the important points  precisely of the
new action of the government in
France and of what we are going to carry out in
Europe because many things that
we have to do at the level of the climate
and well can be done at
European level and must be done at
European level if  we want to act effectively
to tax polluting companies or
protect ourselves from polluting imports
if we want to act to make air transport
less polluting if we want to act
to get rid of pesticides completely
we have to do it at European level if
you can't do it at European level  a
country we have an integrated market cij
imposes immeasurable efforts on our farmers
with their
Spanish or Italian neighbors
they will tell me you are killing French agriculture
you won't change the
products that are in the
household basket every saturday and it's true if i
say i'm going to tax polluting companies
in france and rightly
many tell me where you're going to kill our
jobs the same companies will
go  install in belgium in germany or
elsewhere and they will pollute as much and
it is true and therefore it is at
european level that we have this ambition
led france a few weeks ago to
sedhiou launched with the netherlands this
initiative we have  nine member states
that have joined us and germany
is moving towards us on this
point so we will pursue this
but you are absolutely right the
green environmental message is
a very strong message from these elections and
I take it
within the framework  of the responsibility for
the action that we have to lead
both in france and in europe
[Music]
the background the projects and the progress I
consider that my role is on the basis
of  what I have just told you to
bring together we have to build both
a project a platform for action for
all the pro-European forces and
we have to choose the people who
will be able to carry it and embody
which ones need  a double
majority in the european parliament
majority in the european council
that's what we need to build that's
what i discussed with several of my
colleagues i will now join
the members of v4 as the
group is called  from
visegrad i will then also see donald tusk
i will see angela merkel and several
other leaders and we will continue to
move forward i will report to you right
after
[Music]